we are now ready to talk about the
disastrous and humiliating aftermath of
the house Speaker Fiasco now I don't
know how many of you followed it closely
over the weekend I I did not uh after a
vote number seven I guess on Friday or
whatever day it was I just checked out
and said I'm sure by Monday we'll we
will have figured out what happened and
indeed we have
um Kevin McCarthy was indeed elected
Speaker of the House eventually on the
15th round of voting and it all became a
farce it all became a joke there was a
physical altercation on the house floor
in which Republican members were
grabbing each other it's it's completely
surreal that this is what happened
Marjorie Taylor green now as a result is
like abandoning Q Anon and then the Q
Anon people are furious with Marjorie
Taylor green it's there's four five or
six different layers of absurdity that
now are following what happened on the
floor of the House of Representatives
but they have a speaker okay and it's
Kevin McCarthy and one of the things we
have to recognize and I I mean ideally
they would recognize it in the
Republican party I'm not sure they do
is that they have weakened the
speakership to its weakest Point
certainly in decades in the decades that
uh uh many of us have been following
politics people who are roughly my age
uh this is now a speakership that is
more of a joke than it has ever been
before this is a speakership that is
weaker in terms of its ability and uh
Power at coalescing consensus between
even their own party and you don't need
to look very far to see how quickly this
entire thing became a joke shortly after
the big win for Kevin McCarthy he
announced the very first thing that they
would be doing and listen to what it was
I know the night is late
but when we come back our very first
bill
will appeal the funding for 87 000.
and there's Marjorie Taylor green
clapping
very like just painfully stupid now I've
already debunked the whole thing about
the IRS agents it's I'm not going to do
it now because it's not the point but we
have so many different and important
issues in this country that we could be
working towards fixing and the idea that
the American people would even remotely
benefit from that as opposed to anything
else is laughable one other funny moment
when it was announced that Donald Trump
got one vote during one of the votes for
speaker I believe it was Matt Gates the
entire room just laughs The Honorable
Donald J Trump of the State of Florida
has received one
yeah it really is a joke the entire
thing has turned into a joke and
obviously it was also political drama of
the highest order it got clicks it got
ratings but the entire speaker Fiasco
really at the end of the day is an
exercising extreme irony and one of our
subreddit users wrong sir wrong pointed
out a lot of the ways in which this was
extraordinarily ironic so I'm going to
use their post as a jumping off point
here to talk more about this the 20
house members who initially defected for
lack of a better term
in a way they are the ones standing by
their principles in the sense that they
are some of the most insane and extreme
members of the House Kevin McCarthy was
very much willing to trade votes for
power or influence and he did it based
on what we've been told with committee
assignments and with other things those
20 to the extent that they stuck it out
they weren't willing to trade
assignments or whatever for votes
because they thought that Kevin McCarthy
was a terrible candidate now the reason
they thought that is because McCarthy
isn't nearly as Extreme as they are
right so we have to understand that's
really Bonkers but they at least had
some principle principle where so many
of these these other people have
absolutely no principles whatsoever
that's been a theme of The Last many
years these Republicans sort of claimed
to have values
but they really don't it's whatever
values are convenient to them at the
time and as soon as those values are
inconvenient or inconsistent with
getting what they need in terms of power
they abandon the values we saw this 180
that Marjorie Taylor green did Marjorie
Taylor green after years of portraying
herself as I'm anti-establishment I'm
not a sellout I'm against rhinos all of
this stuff she does a 180 and she
supports Kevin McCarthy who is the
Republican establishment because it
seems as though McCarthy promised her a
sliver of influence if he wins and she's
going to get back on some committee
assignments and whatever else the case
may be that's extraordinarily ironic and
another example of how they don't really
have principles Marjorie Taylor Green's
principles are really the creation of a
character that she believes will be a
character that can gain power and
influence also Marjorie Taylor green has
been criticizing defecting Republicans
for not playing ball and wanting
attention but that's exactly what
Marjorie Taylor green did to get herself
to where she is now she has been the
epitome of the attention seeker and now
she's criticizing others for trying to
get attention we're going to look at an
interview later in which Marjorie Taylor
green actually says this you know all
these holdouts were just trying to get
attention
well everything you've done has been to
get attention
and now all of a sudden you're getting
attention because you say that they are
doing the wrong thing and you're doing
the right thing and then Kevin McCarthy
of course by appeasing Marjorie Taylor
green now creates a generation of
Marjorie Taylor green wannabes in
Congress who will make a show out of
obstructing as much as possible and then
eventually coming to the table getting
something some crumbs in the
negotiations and subsequently getting
power first you yell you yell you yell
to get attention then you say well
you're going to want to make me go away
give me some power and so now that's
going to encourage more and more people
to do that
um and then lastly as again as pointed
out by this user on our subreddit wrong
sir wrong
for years and years McCarthy groveled to
Trump he wanted Trump to endorse him for
the speakership groveling groveling
Trump did the endorsement sort of
half-heartedly at the end of the day if
we're honest but Trump did the
endorsement but it turns out that that
endorsement didn't even get McCarthy the
speakership Trump did the endorsement on
I think it was Wednesday night and many
many more votes in which McCarthy lost
eventually it was a different sort of
negotiation that got McCarthy the
speakership so it's another sign of how
through his endorsement we actually
noticed that Trump is even more weakened
than we previously thought
uh and it's irony all the way down quite
frankly this is a very inauspicious
start for the next two years and we know
they're going to go after Joe Biden we
know they're going to go after Hunter
Biden we know they're going to obstruct
everything they can and so now Democrats
are going to have to think long and hard
to use Donald Trump's phrase
um about what is the best way to get the
most possible out of the next two years
and to mitigate damage to the extent
that they can
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with it's fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below